we haven't talked about autonomous
vehicles for a while we've talked a lot
about the coming uh AI revolution but we
have news out of Michigan specifically
in terms of autonomous vehicles Michigan
has approved a series of bills which
will allow driverless cars with no
passengers and with I'm sorry but with
yes with no steering wheels and without
passengers to be on public roadways and
this is Governor Rick Snyder who has
signed for bills a spark part of what is
being called an autonomous vehicle
legislative package whereas before you
could only do testing of the vehicles by
manufacturers he now is joining the
primary bill a sponsor senator mike cole
as well as executives from General
Motors and Ford and as I told you
earlier in the year pittsburgh has
started live tests of driverless uber
taxis and this is a joint sort of
venture with ford fusions that are that
are uber vehicles they still require
having obviously a steering wheel and
someone sitting a live driver sitting in
the Pat in the driver's seat ready to
take over if anything happens but we're
seeing legislation expand to many states
now 16 states introduce legislation
related to autonomous cars in 2015 12
states did in 2014 and since 2012 we've
seen some kind of autonomous vehicle
registration in 34 states and DC we also
saw a few months ago the National
Highway Transportation and Safety
Administration create some guidelines
for carmakers which talk about sort of
frameworks for what should be in
autonomous vehicle legislation there's
one bill that for example exempts
mechanics from damage to vehicles that
results from repairs assuming that they
were made with manufacturer guidelines
and this is starting to sort of fill out
the lack of coherent law around
liability and on
this vehicles who is responsible if an
autonomous vehicle does X Y or Z is it
the company that designed the logic that
is followed by the autonomous vehicle is
it the individuals at the company that
designed the logic they're very it very
unlikely that it would go that way and
this applies to mechanics and repairs
and so many other areas I still find it
very funny that we still have people in
our audience who will contact me anytime
we talk about autonomous cars this has
been happening for years we've been
talking about autonomous cars off and on
for years I get angry email from people
saying David it's not happening it's
never going to happen we're not going to
have autonomous cars at one point it was
sort of being unwilling to see the
trends now it's just straight up
ignoring of reality there are autonomous
vehicles already operating we have a
driverless truck corridor in Nevada in
the United States that is being tested
with autonomous large transportation
vehicles big rigs as they're often known
it's happening period and at this point
to deny the reality it's sort of like
denying the reality that automation is
going to kill jobs and pretending like
everything's going to remain the same we
would all be so much better off if we
accepted the reality and started
thinking about the big questions that
these new realities will raise uh the
biggest hurdle what will be the biggest
hurdle for autonomous cars will it be
human acceptance will it be the
technological issues that I generally
believe are going to be worked out is it
going to be uh lobbying groups that are
very much against it probably some
combination of all of these things